على طاوله الزعيمين الروسي والصيني ملفات
كثيره شراكه وتعاون وغرب يجتمعان عليه
اهميه كبيره للعلاقات الصينيه الروسيه
وهناك منطق تاريخي وراء ذلك لاننا اكبر
دولتين متجاورتين بالاضافه الى اننا شركاء
استراتيجيون
يساهم تفاعلنا على الساحه الدوليه بشكل
عام بالطبع في تعزيز المبادئ الاساسيه
لنظام العالمي وتعدد الاقطاب
اوكرانيا لم تغب طبعا فصين صاحبه خطه
السلام يقول بوتين ان روسيا تلقت المقترحه
باهتمام
لقد درسنا بعنايه مقترحاتك لحل الازمه
الحاده في اوكرانيا ستتاح لنا الفرصه
لمناقشه هذه المساله وسنناقش بالطبع كل
هذه القضايا
البيت الابيض يراقب وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتقد الصين واعتبر ان بكين توفر
غطاء دبلوماسيا لروسيا لمواصله الجرائم في
اوكرانيا
ان زياره الرئيس تشيى الى روسيا بعد ايام
من اصدار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لمذكره
توقيف بحق الرئيس بوتين تشير الى ان الصين
لا تشعر باي مسؤوليه في محسبه كرملين على
الفضاء التي ارتكبت في اوكرانيا
وبالتزامن مع هذه الزياره اعلنت وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه عن تزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه ومعدات بقيمه 350 مليون دولار